non
[Musique]
coline et anne-cécile sont des guides un
peu particulière leurs livres d'histoire
est rempli de notes de musique est long
mais ne publie dans une visite musicale
du musée d'archéologie nationale
la musique étant l'un des universaux de
notre humanité redécouvrir les
collections avec le prisme de la musique
était plutôt intéressant sachant qu on a
en plus quelques instruments ça notre
musée et s'était du coup l'occasion d'un
de se rencontrer et d'échanger et de
partager autour de deux thèmes communs
qui sont la musique voici finalement
notre région
[Musique]
pour ce nouveau projet le musée a fait
appel à l'ensemble calliopée un ensemble
d'artistes accueilli en résidence cette
visite musicale spécialement conçu pour
dialoguer avec les collections l'idée
c'est de reprendre ce fil conducteur de
respecter l'histoire qu'au proposé que
raconte le musée mais de prendre la
thématique du monde sonore
depuis les pierres les silex depuis les
flux d'historique ce qui sont ici c'est
un miracle qu'elle soit l'un et de se
l'approprier pour se dire mais ça ce
sont mes origines chanteuse et
musicienne font découvrir des morceaux
oubliés mais garde en tête les grands
noms comme mozart ou de lui si je trouve
ça très intéressant très agréable à la
fois de pouvoir voir des vrais
instruments dans les vitrines
et puis d'écouter de la musique d'être
guidé comme ça parle pas des flûtes j'ai
vraiment bien aimé c'est c'est
extraordinaire on a vraiment rêver dans
différentes époques c'était vraiment
magnifique pour moi une visite originale
qui s'inscrit dans le programme c'est
mon patrimoine à découvrir qu'on soit
mélomanes curieux chaque premier
dimanche du mois
non
[Musique]